Hey youtubers, it's Charlie! Thanks everyone
that submitted questions on my Captain America
Civil War Trailer video. I think we're all
still freaking out a little. But this is a
very Netflix 'n Chill type of week, just because
not a whole lot of other stuff is happening.
Seriously if you haven't started watching
Jessica Jones now's the time to do that let's
get the question so here we go Ruben Brown
asks is it true that Peter Parker was cut
out of the movie why would they do that you
much! Well he's not confirmed to be out of
the movie he's not confirmed to be in the
movie but Kevin fight he has left a lot of
interviews were he said people just kind of
take for granted that he's in there when you
think about the movies model has coming next
year that Captain America Civil War in the
spring and then they have Doctor strange happening
at the end of the year Tom Holland Spiderman
is supposed to be introduced in a marble film
in the marble cinematic universe then the
year after that cocoa into his own first solo
film the first film in a new trilogy at Sony
with Marvel's help of you did a big comic
book arc like say Civil War wouldn't it make
the most sense to you Spiderman who is a big
part of that arc in comic books Civil War
with the thought is Buetow because the arrangement
that they worked out with Sony and in the
way Spiderman works in the marble cinematic
universe he's not can it be as big a character
as Captain America are Iron Man is going to
be important part of the story is not a very
huge presence in the film when you think of
the scope of Spiderman's role in comic books
Civil War like he's a huge part of it think
of that is going to Black Panther in movies
Civil War marble owns 100% of the movie rights
to Black Panther so of course are going to
focus on him more is getting it is on solo
film eventually two so that they can spend
more time with Black Panther than that will
Spiderman most of the conversation about Spiderman
isn't so much about whether or not he's going
to be in Civil War it's going to be what his
costume is gonna look like it's supposed to
start out superlow five like the kind of costume
to normal 15-year-old child would create so
I definitely think he's in there but it's
kind of a Luke Skywalker thing where they
don't put him in any of the trailers like
you don't see into the actual film next question
Michael asks who do you think will end up
winning this war Charlie size as you talk
about Captain America are Iron Man if if you've
read comic books Civil War I do think it will
go down in a very similar way because that's
kind of spoil re-I'm not can it say how that
ends if you don't have a Marvel unlimited
account I think they have a lot of Civil War
in the stuff that comes after on Marvel unlimited
you just have to double check on I've been
buying most of my comics through comics all
due lately I haven't been using Marvel unlimited
that much recently but I definitely think
that they're going to go for the big twist
at the end of comic books Civil War I think
they be wasting a big opportunity they didn't
try even though most of the world knows what
happens during comic books Civil War that's
gonna be really funny awkward situation that
the Star Wars films are not in episode seven
has the advantage of being a completely new
story that's not based on anything else next
question do you IT asks I know this sounds
strange my favorite scene was when Captain
America's confronted by Iron Man Says it's
been a long day you can feel the tension in
that scene and is much as I love the action
and see my favorite heroes the solid acting
performances in those 10 scenes is amazing
so yet that's that's really where Robert Downey
Junior and those other actors shine is when
they're doing the drama stop using when their
pitching the stories to the actors the like
okay what's my character going to be doing
in this what's his arc they talk about these
types of scenes the big twist or just kind
of signpost that they use to demarcate acts
of the film like on this act this is going
to be the big twist with them when they fill
it in with all those character moments that's
when it becomes an actual movie like a lot
of these big films are roller coasters there's
there's the roller coaster part were just
like the thrill like oh my God this is happening
everything is exploding on screen is going
crazy and then there's the really human moments
that you relate to like when you connect with
the characters like Captain Bucky their friendship
next question Patrick asks where was the vision
I don't want to see spider Manitoba movie
hopefully they learned from avengers interval
Tron and art releasing as many clubs what
I think you're going to be disappointed if
you don't think they're going to be releasing
a ton of clubs there's any all kinds of this
movie but the vision is probably just not
a huge part of the film so the pry using this
first trailer to focus on the biggest stuff
even though half of the avengers are going
to be in the movie this is still a Captain
America movie so most of the film like most
the scenes will follow his perspective like
him walking around interacting with all the
different characters vision is just a really
interesting presence because he's so powerful
he still has the mind gem which we all know
fantasy is good have to take from them at
some point to form the infinity gauntlet so
he's probably not long for this world but
the cool thing is if you have read a lot of
scarlet which vision stories of the other
big relationship they've had in the comics
for a long time she is supposed to be teen
He's supposed to be team Iron Man so he will
get the season fun Easter eggs for other comic
book rivalries nobody can fight like lovers
fight and you can you can write as many fixes
you want about this film there's going to
be so much big on teller it's gonna be ridiculous
to just be aware of the tumbler tags that
you're searching you might you might find
something that you didn't want to see next
question Guyon guy asks who team are you on
that session good question I think I pry be
team captains because he's kind of the underdog
he's the man the fights against the system
there's nothing wrong with choosing team Iron
Man if they did their job writing the film
then there will be no clear side to take like
everyone will have a good perspective Iron
Man just wants to make the world a Safer place,
Captain America's all about civil liberties
see you should be conflicted but it but I
think everybody's going to have their favorite
going into this obviously to see if people
enter the film wanting to be on one team and
leave the film wishing that they were on the
other team you come in Captain America the
end of sympathizing with Iron Man more at
the end of the film next question chat see
asks the avengers called power people enhanced
like agent to shield it before learning about
inhumans pretty sure that the term inhumans
is still only used within shield and they're
trying to keep them secret from the world
you think you have the right idea they're
getting use that term enhanced or gifted during
Captain America Civil War although I do think
the inhumans movie is still supposed to be
happening out there still trying to make it
happen so I think it is certain point they
will become a public being in the avengers
will start using that term that will probably
happen sometime around infinity wars they
had in the face for I think phase for you
see a lot more inhuman stuff happening in
the movie universe another a lot of rumors
about the inhumans movie being tanked when
Kevin fight and marvels Studios kind of broke
off into their own group but as far as I know
it's still on the boards like it's still gonna
happen eventually the interesting thing the
Vin diesel has said about the inhumans and
black bolt specifically is that is not so
much about him courting Marvel is about Marvel
courting him with the right script that he
made it sound like Marvel is totally down
with him being Black Bolt it just that they
haven't found the right script yet next question
A-OK asks what does the punisher series come
out is it before after daredevil season two
let me know will definitely have to be after
because the punisher is only showing up for
the first time in daredevil season two but
the rumor is is that they like him so much
they like John Bernthal's performance so much
that they're going to try and stick them in
a whole much other stuff there couple options
think that you give him his own series which
I think is the most likely thing or they could
just put him in a bunch of other series and
I think for the most part the gonna keep him
local to the Netflix series so like Luke Cage
iron fist daredevil although series the Netflix
characters are supposed appear in infinity
war and some kind of way like after they become
the defenders are supposed to show up in infinity
war so that be the logical place to stick
punisher in the movies like he's not going
to show up in Thor Ragnarok punisher in the
movies when the other Netflix characters go
to the movies but I want John Bernthal to
do though is dress-up in his punisher costume
and crashed the Captain America Civil War
press tour and have Chris Evans just said
no dude you are way too crazy we don't want
your help please go home that's kind of what
happens during comic books Civil War with
team The like okay thanks for helping us out
punisher but you are way too crazy for us
wanted just just go home to go to your own
thing next question Marybeth asks is more
more movies are made it seems like they stand
less and less on their own for someone that
hasn't read the comic books and watched only
a few prior movies in the marvel series what's
the best order to watch the movies to better
understand everything leading up to this movie
assume you're talking about Captain America
Civil War deed watching the TV shows as well
if he if you really wanted to you could skip
all the TV shows like you don't need to watch
those and I would just watch the movies in
chronological order just to keep it simple
if you go to marvels movie wiki page it has
a list for all their movies in the chronological
order in which they appear just watch them
in that order is real simple where you start
watching the movies just depends on how familiar
you feel like you are with the characters
like if you already know who the avengers
are like you know who Doris you know Captain
America's you probably just start with the
phase 2 movies but if you are a glutton for
punishment you could totally marathon every
single Marvel movie in chronological order
and watch all the seasons of all the TV shows
at least the live-action shows the car to
storylines don't have anything to do with
the movies thank you so much everyone for
70 questions is always a ton of fun to do
a pretty down weeks am in a try and do Q&A's
for much other stuff like game of thrones
maybe some Star Wars Q&A's two but congratulations
to the giveaway winner Jarvis Bailey awesome
name you and the movie gift certificates just
be sure to private message me on the back
and my channels and get your contact info
if any of you guys just found me in the last
week or so like your new to my channel to
use the giveaways every week for marvel DC
Star Wars stuff game of thrones all kinds
awesome stuff if you're not sure about how
that stuff works just watch a couple my videos
from other fandoms it's real simple I try
to keep it as simple as possible what's going
to happen next is there's a bunch of Jessica
Jones that I have to finish there's a game
of thrones Q&A that I want to do is little
bit more Star Wars there's some more flash
and arrow stuff and some DC movies stuff to
the release some more information about Doctor
strange as well Mads Mikkelsen was confirmed
for Doctor strange so I am super pumped about
that probably playing Dormmamu but we can
talk about that when I post my next Doctor
strange video be sure to subscribe to get
everything and I totally take requests, so
if there's videos that you don't see me doing
that you guys really want me to do, feel free
to let me know in the comments. Just in case
you guys want to watch it like 15 billion
more times you can click here for the Captain
America Civil War trailer and you can click
here for all my Jessica Jones videos this
is the week to catch up on Jessica Jones thank
you so much for watching everybody high five
and I'll see you guys tonight!